[Music]
we apologize that jingle will stay with
you all day long if there is a serious
story here to report the charity behind
that familiar ad kars4kids
is the subject of a troubling new report
the group one of the country's largest
vehicle donation charities is accused of
misleading donors Minnesota's Attorney
General says cars for kids spent less
than 1% of the millions of dollars that
it raised in Minnesota on charitable
programs for children their tonita copal
shows us a growing scrutiny of the
charities practices Tony good morning
good morning cars for kids runs very
effective ad campaigns you could
probably sing the whole jingle right now
but the Minnesota Attorney General is
joining a chorus of states with
complaints against the charity about how
much of the money being raised by car
donations is going to kids and where
that money is being spent the cars for
kids jingle makes a simple request the
song has weathered the wrath of comets
shut up but new revelations about the
charity are no laughing matter according
to the Minnesota Attorney General
between 2012 and 2014 cars for kids
raised 3 million dollars in the state
through car donations but less than 12
thousand dollars went to Minnesota kids
and I think it's important when people
donate to a charity that they have
information in terms of where their
money is going where does the money go
ninety percent of the monies donated go
to a sister organization Ora a new
jersey-based charity that operates
Jewish youth summer camps in New York
Danielpour cough is president of charity
watch my main concern about cars for
kids is that people don't know what's
really happening with this charity
that's fine if people want to raise
money for Orthodox Jews but they need to
be clear in state that's what the
purpose is cars for kids issued a
statement since we are headquartered in
the Northeast many of our programs and
recipients naturally come from this area
we believe Minnesota residents
appreciate that their generous donations
to Kars for kids help children both in
and out of state the Minnesota Attorney
Jan
had other concerns as well claiming that
the charity lost almost ten million
dollars in real estate transactions
invested the money and then lost the
money and we think that too is something
important for people to know and the
2015 budget for those ads seventeen
million dollars according to charity
watch even more than kars4kids gave to
aura so when one makes a donation to
kars4kids
they're basically paying for those ads
and it's worth noting that in 2009 car's
paid settlements in Oregon and
Pennsylvania after those states charged
the charity with misleading donors as
for Minnesota's report the charity says
they've had conversations with the
attorney general's office and they are
reviewing suggestions you know one of
the things I've never really figured out
about that advertisement is one eight
seven seven cars for kids too many
letters for a phone number where does
the phone number begin I guess I just
started the D I don't know we're not
illegal not a legal matter but worth
looking at one of our super brains Jim
Axelrod pointed that out in the
greenroom he's coming up next we will
ask him to figure that out by the time
he says yeah it is very good that's a
good observation thank you Tony